[Music]
hey guys George hamil here with another
minute money hack today's hack is
slightly less painful than stepping on
Legos you guessed it we're talking taxes
now you may be watching because you
haven't filed yet and to make matters
worse
you're wasting time on the internet
watching some millennial harass you for
procrastinating plus you're probably
wondering how is this guy qualified to
give me a tax advice well I'm not but I
have access to a camera crew and you
don't so here we are hit the clock are
you a receipt hoarder and you know who
you are Jeff it's time to become a
minimalist if you're itemizing you can
download apps like shoebox expense IQ
and gas tracker to ditch the paper once
and for all if your income is under
66,000 then check out the IRS free file
software and see if you're eligible
don't miss out on deductions and credits
you might qualify for including your HSA
FSA IRA 401k idk just google the rest
the point is there's a ton of deductions
you might be missing out on for example
if you're a professional bodybuilder you
can write off body oil and spray tans as
a business expense no pain
no capital gain
[Music]
save time and money by working with a
pro it takes around two hours to file
with a pro versus an average of 13 hours
on your own and with the time you say if
you could watch the entire Lord of the
Rings trilogy extended editions now I'm
not saying you should do that but I am
saying you could and there's your minute
money hack
[Music]